when you start doing this where you're
with your long-term partner already yeah
yeah so she saw you go through the
process of starting this journey
did she make any observations about you
throughout it like how it affected you
she thought I was batshit crazy
um
and after a massive breakdown she found
me hanging
oh god really yeah God I didn't know
about that Mike yeah
[Music]
so Mike welcome back it's the third
video we've done together it's great to
see you again
um I'm going to be getting into what
you've been doing and what's changed but
first of all I think there is one very
big change isn't it yeah
yeah I'm no longer pedophile man
um it's been a mad Journal mad my
journey but
um it was necessary you know it was
necessary to kind of
come away from that and go in the
direction that I've gone in what I'd
love to do for potentially new viewers
who didn't see the other videos we did
together is go right back to the
beginning and for you to take me through
your story a little bit what led you
into pedophile hunting yeah of course so
I went through some stuff when I was
younger that I really shouldn't have
done I saw obviously I pedophile online
getting stung
and I've done this thing video and
thought yeah you know I could
more than anything I think I was looking
for answers I never got those answers
but I was looking for answers so
obviously I decided to start a team and
start going out and and catching
predators and and what age are you when
you when you when you saw that first
video
was it well I'm 36 no it was this was
about 30 31 30 because
what I find sort of interesting about
that is if that was me seeing that video
obviously I have different experiences
to you so it wouldn't have the same
impact but I wouldn't know where to
start what was the building blocks of of
beginning from seeing that video to
forming a team for me like from the
beginning of starting I wasn't wasn't
necessarily about what the Predator was
doing or their behavior for me I was
more bothered about the safeguarding
surrounding that so many children that
he had access to or she had access to it
was for me the bigger picture was trying
to protect those kids
um
so I started out with one team
um volunteering for them was I started
out as a decoy I see you started out
working for another team that already
existed yeah yeah it wasn't it wasn't
long-lasted because their view on
safeguarding wasn't the same as mine so
I kind of
got a bit of OCD with things and start
you know started my own team I did have
a mentor
um it kind of helped me through I only
still to this day a good friend of mine
but yeah it wasn't it's not the easiest
of things to get into no I I mean so I
assume that you did you just message a
group on Facebook and say you're
interested in helping yeah and then you
said they set you up as a decoy yeah
what did that involve like what was the
first thing that you ever had to do
speaking is a beautiful house basically
that you know is pretty much what it is
um and that wasn't easy as someone else
with a past like mine it's it's not I
didn't I had no idea when I was going
into it exactly what kind of effect I
was going to have long term
you know right then I just thought I was
kind of
trying to get the answers that I needed
is it like internet or like is it on
your laptop what's going on on your
phone so you know it was different
different apps
[Music]
um
I'm obviously commoners as a child
and you know it's like shooting fish in
a barrel
yeah God like even the first time he'd
ever done it yeah yeah within 20 minutes
of me doing that I was speaking to two
people who were in the little building a
case on
within 20 minutes of the first time
you've ever tried to
God that's sort of a terrifying thing to
hear is that do you think that's an
unusual situation or is that no no it's
this this everywhere
you know the media might play it though
is everywhere and when you say within 20
minutes is that because the apps have a
global reach so you're basically talking
to potentially the whole world or is
that like local no these were people in
the UK
God right and your reward for doing it
after the sting was basically the
knowledge that that person wasn't
talking to a child that were talking to
you and then no well it's not even that
it's if they've got access to children
say you know there was quite a few
people that were caught who were parents
you know so this this person is living a
double life living in a house if he
swims or his daughters but your sons and
daughters and
he's trying to Children what he believes
to be children sexually online like what
about his children he's checking them
so for me it goes back to that power of
one thing the power of one is something
I think you made that up for your own
Mantra wasn't it it was to believe it or
not it was my mentor that taught me
about that he started out if you can
make a difference in one person's life
in a day then why are you not going to
do that
but then once you've done one carry on
and carry on whereas for me all I wanted
to do was stop one kid going through
what I I went through as a child
on an obviously I won't apply that as
many times as I could
but the base level was always making the
difference to One Life anything above
that essentially yeah yeah all right
let's go back so you've done the you've
done your first kind of conversation via
text
when did it progress to you doing your
first thing to actually being face to
face with uh an offender
I'd started my own team and I had some
decoys that come with me from the team
that I've volunteered with
and we kind of set up that light
but they'd already been speaking one of
them had already been speaking to a guy
who was based in Darlington and it was
it happened very very quickly like I
didn't expect it to happen that quick we
literally had the evidence he was meant
to turn up with his
um
with his campervan and second 13 year
old girls to a campsite
where he intended on what we started
doing this
what he said he was going to do
um he failed to turn up at the meeting
point but we found out that he had
children so we we managed to track down
his address and we went to Darlington
and stung him they confronted him at his
house yeah yeah wow yeah how did that
like the first time you're doing
something like that how like going into
it how did it feel the adrenaline was
Matt yeah I think when I got home
I literally sat up all night and just
kind of
it was kind of an Awakening but at the
same time it was like
what just you know I mean what just what
just happened
imagine a lot of emotions to process
yeah it's it's an emotional thing more
than anything like
I'll be honest the first one it was that
element of guilt oh really because I'd
gone in and obviously even though he'd
done wrong I saw his wife's reaction
and that you know it I kind of went away
with mixed emotions from that
um which has to detached myself from you
know it took me a while to kind of get
my head round up but it's not you know
it's not the wife
it's it's them that's brought us to
their door you know it's the perpetrator
that's brought us to that door so with
situations like that
when you turn up at someone's door
I can imagine for the partner there's a
probably a a feeling of maybe denial
disbelief disbelief but then I guess you
turn up with a body of evidence that
proves it's the case was that the case
in this time like was it something that
you could see that she knew was true you
know would she tell you to leave would
you telling you to get away it's not
here more no it was um the way she
described afterwards was that
when we arrived just before half past
seven
it was the most kind loving person that
she'd ever met and then obviously when
we turned up and and she'd seen the
evidence and he'd admitted what what
he'd done she said you've left me with a
monster
you know but the thing is from the first
one we always made sure if there was
going to be a spouse present that we had
females that would go in with a copy of
the evidence to show them if they wanted
to see it to to make them understand the
reasons as to why we were there
I guess it's it's such a complicated
thing as well for her to process isn't
it because like when you say she said
you've left me with a monster but she
was living with a monster it's just
you've kind of shown her the reality of
who he was there was a whole concept of
the heartlight it was about being that
light
you know exposing them for what what
they really are so with the first one
you've gone in there you've kind of
you've confronted someone face to face
prior to this you've been doing it by
text right you've been doing decoy work
you've been messaging this is the first
one you face to face
what did it feel like as someone who had
experienced the kind of trauma that you
had as a young person to see someone
face to face that you knew was capable
of inflicting that on someone else
it's a good question
scarily I was there was like um an Airy
calm that came over me
um and I think
you know since I've since I've stopped
doing that I've you know I've spoken to
a professor in Psychology and what that
actually comes down to the whole hunting
thing is trauma what's called trauma
reenactment
so actually what I was doing I was not
reliving my own trauma but I was going
through the trauma process
to try and get control over what
happened to me when I was a kid because
he had no control over it
okay does that make sense so it was like
you're trying to repeat the thing that
happened but this time you're the one
that's in control yeah I was in controls
so it took me a while to get me head
around it but once you know once I
finally got mad around it it made
perfect sense
and then following on from that would
that mean that everything you did after
that was a form of rate trauma
reenactment I would say so yeah and so
we're finding closure by doing them no I
was I was still seeking answers at that
point
you know what I think when it started
out I really really wanted answers to
what I don't know I don't know
but then I realized that it's not
actually answers that I need it's
acceptance
if that makes sense like there's nothing
I can do to change what happened to me
as a kid nothing
so what you know
the way I see it is that I can't keep
going back
can't keep living in the dark I can't
keep concentrating on everything that's
that's negative about the trauma that I
went through when there's so many
positive things that have come out of it
what you know kind of in the direction
of what I'm doing now and moving away
from the hunting side of it so
you you do the first thing it's a
success I guess you'd call it
um how many do you think you did up to
the point you decided to call it a day
how many stings do you think you're
involved in I don't even know
say probably about four or five hundred
different right well that's not
necessarily me going out and stinging
them but that's giving advice to other
teams or trying to track them or making
sure there's enough evidence within the
chat log to be able to get the police to
charge him you know it's a really really
intricate thing
to do and you've got to make sure it's
done right so obviously there was a lot
of when new teams came about
I'd like to help him if that makes sense
because I started out not knowing
anything
so you know I wanted to try and help
with as many people get it right as as
we could because again it just comes
back to the power of one and
safeguarding one of the comments in the
previous video that a few people said
was oh this is this is legally
entrapment and it means they can't be
prosecuted entrapments was messaging
them I say I was I'm not doing it
anymore but entrapment would be a
pedophile on there are only in groups
and in the first message that never
happens ever so how do you make them
send the first message to you the
profiles of diamond it's just the email
profiles of what appears to be young
kids
set up on you know Facebook and things
like that and then they'll send the
first message
and obviously they'll get a reply as a
child and then right the way through it
will be and do you sort of early doors
say the age of the profile yeah yeah
yeah within the first few messages and
are we talking about on the edge like 15
16 are we talking about no no it's right
11 12 30. and then it continues every
time
there's the odd one that blocks well
then nine times out of ten they'll
unblock and
it's almost testing the water a little
bit so with with the profiles
the the other thing that I noticed that
some people are asking about is do you
use pictures of real children no no
never how do you set up
um
when my page was up and running there
was 160 000 people on it you know we're
a big following so what we do is we'd
request
from our followers
historic pitches have damaged children
to be donated to us so we could use
those pictures to obviously speak to the
predatorism and build profiles around
their pictures
um you know obviously and in doing that
they donate the pictures and we'd have
assigned agreement with them that we can
use their pictures and that we won't
keep them informed of any cases that
their pictures are used in
um but it never pictures of real
children it's it just defeats the object
on it obviously when you're talking to
these people I imagine some of the
messages are deeply unpleasant I've
watched a couple of documentaries that
have been made by different companies
online about sting operations stuff like
that it always seems like there's two
types of people the ones that break down
into tears because they realize what's
just about to happen to them and what's
now happened to the rest of their lives
and the ones that are almost like
yeah yeah is that what was that your
experience yeah yeah yeah what was the
kind of typical reaction to being stung
the cold gray really
yeah but I used to find out uh you know
it sounds a bit sadistic but I used to I
used to find pleasure in that um I used
to love watching the color drain out of
them because there's the Dan the pennies
dropped you know there's that
realization that they've [ __ ]
basically but okay you know it's
I've not done it for so long now it's
it's not even looking back and thinking
about it to be honest
but doing that as a kind of consistent
thing over and over again it must give
you a bleak view of the world right
um
I think in in doing something like that
you're looking at the world but you're
only looking at the darkness in the
world
if that makes sense you're only
concentrating on on
the worst of the worst
so yeah it does give you a bleak outlook
on the world but when
I don't know you know there's a lot of
teams out there that are still doing it
a lot of teams that are still active and
you know what they take me out after him
genuinely I do but I couldn't be in that
dark space anymore it is a very very
dark space to be into especially when
you you know you've got real parents
contacting you and their kids have been
groomed and things uh it's just would
that happen people really what would
they want from you
um one case in particular was um two
young girls and the grandmother
contacted me I would have been groomed
on a tablet that their father had left
in the house after the mum and dad had
split up and the oldest girl went on the
tablet
um
and realized because he just thought she
was playing on Barbie games or you know
and she'd actually been speaking to
somebody on an app that Dad had left on
on the thing
um she was groomed talking to two other
platforms
made to do things to herself oh God she
was only eight
um I made to take pictures of it of a
sister in a bath
and the grandmother contacted me and she
said
Social Services have done nothing and
I'm not taking shots of professionals
but Social Services have done nothing
um the police were obviously
investigating it but the the oldest girl
are giving out the address to the
perpetrator
I have a home and she and she was
petrified that you know they were going
to come round and the social worker did
you know in in speaking to the council
wasn't looking to get him relocated or
or anything like that
but the girl was traumatized by the fact
that she'd done some of these things in
the bathroom to herself
and she was wet in the bed and she ended
up with an eating disorder and you know
all these different things and no one
was helping him so she contacted me and
obviously I you know I rang around the
local Authority and tried to do things
as much as I could not I had any special
powers but trying to do things to to
help
would they ever find her
perpetrator not that I know I've known
when you say that that she had a she was
left an iPad that then she was groomed
on
I think a turning point in my mind was I
suppose before doing the first video
with you I'd seen
the pedophile his like as a kind of
Hysteria like something that the
tabloids drop into if it's a slow news
day where they say oh you know there's
this pedophile Panic around the country
and I suppose
it was something that I thought was
probably a danger but not prevalent it
was something I thought they you know
boosted up for for kind of like numbers
and I remember
um we were in that room back there and
you put an app on your phone and said
look I'll show you did you just opened
yeah before we shot and you opened an
app and said I'm showing you how to
search for pedophile groups in this app
and you did it and it wasn't like five
it was like you couldn't ever exercise
yeah you could never get to the bottom
of the scroll of them
and that like really shocked me because
I'm still active
it's still active right now but
I guess
is it do you think this is something
that's always been there it's just not
been as well known or or do you think
it's something that's getting worse
beautifully has always been those you
know it's and it's always going to be
there it's just with the Boomer social
media and these things it just makes it
so much easier for people to be
um
a completely different entertain behind
the screen
you know you can be anyone you want to
be behind the screen and I think that's
where the real problem lies is because
a vulnerable
young girl or young boy who's speaking
to someone online they might be
vulnerable because the parents don't pay
attention or they've got significant
trauma going on at home or within the
family and they're kind of detached away
from the family unit kind of thing and
they've got this person showering them
with with compliments and praise and
you're amazing kind of stuff and
obviously to buy into it don't know
because it's
smoker mirrors
um
and I saw so many kids get dragged into
it it's horrible
it is and do you think that um a lot of
the parents are sort of of the mindset I
was where it's not as big an issue and
therefore leave devices to be
sort of used by kids without being
checked frequently I think since
pedophile woman is you know that's one
thing I can say is that it's definitely
increased the level of awareness
but still
there's that common misconception that
what happens to my kid
what was your proudest moment during
that period of your life would you say
the young girl
from the first video
with cart someone I mean looking about
the sentence him was ridiculous he only
got eight years but
um yeah she she'd been raped off him
from the age of 12 right the way through
to six deal and she never told anyone
and she saw his picture on our page and
she contacted us and then obviously we
ended up putting her in contact with the
police
on the day after we'd stung him she won
and gave evidence
and that contributed to his sentence
right
but he was a rear founder all right
so with cases like the girl that you
just mentioned the first one obviously
that's made a massive impact on you
because all these years later it's you
know it's something you remember as your
proudest moment do you stay in touch
with victims like that yeah she's just
got a baby oh really yeah
so you get to see how their lives
progress afterwards yeah
not massively I bought with with her in
particular
um
yeah I ended up keeping in contact with
her and she's you know she's doing
incredibly well she got closure from
that
and you know you think of the
the average age of of people disclosing
and people talking about being abused
and raped and all of these different
things for her to have done that at 17
years old
is is huge and I'd like to think that
that's probably the fact that she's got
to do that so young
she's been able to deal with some of the
the trauma earlier on in her life as
opposed to later on in her life and
obviously having the baby
will now contribute to her having that
stability in life to other people
might not have them you know if they've
not disclosed so young in general what
was your relationship like with the
police because obviously what's
presented to us by the major is that the
police and the kind of pedophile Hunters
are kind of constantly but had some
Talent getting each other's way so if
it's done properly you know I've had
um
off you know offender offices that they
always sex offenders saying that we're
the eyes and ears on the ground you know
Peter 500 is all the eisenhairs on the
ground
I missed one officer said to me she says
I've got 125 offenders that I need to
deal with
in a wee car you know whatever period of
time that was and she said I just
haven't got the time
to be able to look for the others so
I'll look for the ones that are
reoffending or you know she said you are
the eyes and ears on the ground well
that's one police officer I never had a
bad you know I've never had a bad
interaction with the police
but obviously there's you know some a
lot of police in the top offices are
against it
the ones on the ground now
you're somebody that um
through all the videos we've made
together so far
um
you've got strong opinions of course the
line of work you were in leads to strong
opinions but I've never felt like much
anger from you at all I've never felt
like I felt very strong opinions about
what you've just said about stuff being
sickening like
I think it'd be hard for me to have done
what you've done and not be
really pissed off all the time not just
from the people you encounter but from
what you say about like putting all that
effort in in small sentences
seeing it not being resourced properly
people being ignored like is that just
your personality or is that something
you try to no Karma what's the way I see
it is there's no point
and this is something I've kind of grown
to to realize there's no point holding
on to negative [ __ ]
I
it serves me no purpose
you know I'm like with the stuff I went
through I'm not in control of it
I'm not in control of the decisions that
the government make in terms of funding
so I you know that's someone else's [ __ ]
to carry icon
take up all my time worrying about all
these different things when I've got a
lot of other things in life to worry
about when you started doing this were
you with your long-term partner already
yeah yeah so she saw you go through the
process of starting this journey
did she make any observations about you
throughout it like how it affected you
she thought I was batshit crazy
um
and after a massive breakdown she found
me hanging
so oh god really yeah God I didn't know
about that Mike yeah was that after we'd
met previously or was that right God so
you know it's like
this is when when you look at that and
you look at the overall
trauma reenactment thing I didn't see
how well it was making me
right
and do you think it was that doing that
job that led you down that path yeah
yeah yeah
all kind of um
hmm
like a train stop building it all
backing up
but I'm still there
thanks to her and was that part of what
pushed you into giving it up yeah well
it's not just I was spending so much
time away from my family
you know I'd gone from being
you know running my own company being a
full-time dad putting my daughter to bed
my daughter was little at the time
giving her a bath you know doing the
weekend thing and I was I was never in
I was always out going going up and down
the country never saw my family
um Family fell apart a lot of Madness
happened
and then
tried going back to it
but I needed a way out and
obviously the way out I found
was
by realizing that instead of me trying
to face it head on
I need to accept the past for what it is
and try and move forward away from it
and that's what I did do you think at
that point when you talk about the sort
of family unit breaking down a bit do
you think it for you it had moved into
an obsession
not an obsession as such but I'd just be
I think I was still at that point I
wasn't I wasn't in recovery
I was still very broken and at the same
time I think I was struggling like I
said last time you know I was I was kind
of struggling with my identity
and
to have realized who I am and what I'm
about and what my morals and principles
are and so I've gone through the
recovery
process into healing now I can see that
obviously doing what I was doing was
part of a stepping stone of of me
getting better and being able to move
forward with my life because now my
family's never been happier than it is
stood out to me that I think what you
said on the phone was you were like this
is as big as a as a video this is as big
as I can get yeah it's as big as the
awareness that I could have put out
there and you said it felt like no one
cared yeah
and when you say no one you mean people
who could actually make a difference
yeah yeah yeah
but somebody said to me after that video
it's all good doing that video but you
know
for you to
make change in the system you've got to
be a part of it
so that's what I did
I think we're gonna talk to somebody
that's helped you do that aren't we
Danny
so when I phoned you this time I texted
you didn't I yeah because I sort of like
tend to stay in touch with people a
little bit and um dropped your line said
sort of what how are you doing and
um said we're thinking about doing a
video catching up with people seeing
where they're at now and you said I'm
happy to do one but there's two
differences I'm gonna have my mask off
yeah and there'll be two of us
do you want to explain yeah excuse me
best mate pretty much
um
while I was Peter Fallon and Dan was
doing his own thing around
um male survivors of sexual abuse and
Trauma
and basically
um I was watching him he was watching me
I sent him a message
um I went to the player support group
but he was running
and it was that that completely changed
everything for me because it was in a
room for the big Burly men who were
talking about things that were
sense if
um
and yeah do you give me the um he opened
the door for me to be able to speak give
me permission to speak
and help me to get onto the world of
recovery do you want to take us through
what that was done yes so I was on
social media and I was watching all
these pedophiles things and I didn't
really like the way they was doing
things and and they come across Mike and
he seemed Dead Calm and he wasn't
shouting and and it was getting results
and stuff and I thought it's great what
he's doing but personally with my kind
of sort of background trauma I've been
through I couldn't do it I wouldn't have
the patience and I don't think I'll keep
my hands off him if I'm quite honest so
that wasn't a route that I wanted to go
on don't go down but I had admiration
for what he was doing because I so
wanted to do it what I was doing at the
time was
um campaigning for men and trying to
roll people to work out to account from
councils who let people down in care
um who'd said nothing screaming and
shouting outside Westminster with a
megaphone and at the Speaker's Corner
but I wasn't getting anywhere no one was
listening it was just some crazy person
who was shouting that's how I dealt with
my trauma that I was like sort of coming
out that way and he was watching me
doing what I was doing thinking he was
thinking how can he speak about this so
publicly and like not have any light so
I shame around what had happened to him
and stuff and
um
and you might be asking was yours within
sexual abuse as well yeah yeah so
um one of the people who sexually abused
me was a family member which was from
five to ten
then when I was older through my home
life and stuff that I am my mom not
being around and that left to like sort
of different family members passed
around the family into loads of
different schools because of my behavior
that was a result of
the trauma that I went through I was
younger I didn't have the words to talk
about it so it came out in behaviors
where it'd be like sort of really not in
school I've been to loads of different
schools kind of sort of moved about
um
nobody ever asked me why nobody ever sat
me down and said Daniel what is up with
you why are you behaving like this or
just labeled a little [ __ ] basically
um which followed me through to
secondary school and what my granddad
had done many sexual abuse me is he
smashed me boundaries I became one of
them kids who never say no so be like
Daniel do this Daniel do that and I do
it because I wanted to fit in what it's
a sense of belonging way people to love
me like me essentially
um but my boundaries was down
um and when I got to 15.
um I was I was befriended and groomed by
a local drug dealer from our area who
got me selling to extreme in school and
stuff
um and
it like my dad wasn't around need like
sort of took me under his wing and stuff
by time I was 15 and a half I'd high
back and everyone in crack I was coming
in school absolutely smashed nobody said
nothing
um it was a guy 10 years older than me
um picking me up from school no teachers
have a question why coming in school
with a mobile phone nobody had mobile
phones at that that point and I was
walking about I think was bad with a
mobile phone clip to me about and that
um but what he was doing is no one ever
picked up on it nobody ever asked me why
it was all about me Behavior do you
think at that point they'd just written
you off they just written me off the
message what I got told at school was
um
you're gonna by the time you leave
school by the time you get to 18 you're
going to end up in prison or dead and I
kind of sort of took that stuff on board
and it became like a self-fulfilling
process prophecy and it did end up in
prison the way I communicated what
happened to me was through my behavior
through misbehaving through attention
seeking through smashing things up
through starting fires all that stuff
was like you'd think someone had sat
down exercise professional curiosity I'm
gone I'm gonna minute what is up with
this kid why is this kid behaving like
that that didn't happen until Emmy 30s
and it's like Mike touched on before I
met someone who was my drug worker and
he sat me down and he said Daniel what
is up with you why are you behaving like
this why are you taking drugs
um you did a little bit of
self-disclosure soft disclosure and he
told me a little about a little bit
about himself
um a little bit about what happened to
him and it was like thank God for that
not like in a weird way or anything but
I'd never spoke to anybody before who'd
as a man in particular who who'd
disclosed that they've been sexually
abused and like Mike said before what he
did that day is to give me permission to
speak
and he like sort of give me the words
and he gave me the confidence and the
courage and I made a promise that day
but I would do that for other people and
that's what happened to Mike not that
I've saved him or anything like that I
just passed on what had been passed on
to me Paid It Forward paid it forward so
with both of you when you were just
talking about there were you were
talking about your experience uh of
meeting the the drugs caseworker yeah
and him giving you some of that
information you talking about going to
Dan's Workshop you both the way you
described it was almost like that it
wasn't a gradual process it was almost
like something going off in your heads
is that right I think one of the key
things Mike and one of the key things
that we've both learned is so this is
the real difficult thing so the last
time that we got vulnerable we were
sexually abused yeah so now yeah what
we've got to learn of someone else is
that vulnerability is the sharpest tool
in your box and that is the thing what's
going to save you so I had to expose my
sort of vulnerabilities talk about what
happened to me yeah to say look this is
the my sharpest too my box is one
mobility yeah and that is only what's
going to get you right yeah you're gonna
have to you gonna have to dig flipping
deep do you know what I mean get
vulnerable talk about what's happened in
order to get well and to get better that
is a massive risk for somebody who's got
trust issues because of what's happened
to the past so the only way that we can
do that is by speaking out on social
media using the Twitter platform it's
interesting when you say they're about
um vulnerability is hard because of the
trust issues that have been you know
given to you
but also would you mind me asking how
old you are done I'm 44. 44 so I imagine
for someone of your age as well when you
were young growing up that sort of
vulnerability also there was a there was
a double level because I think now sort
of openness and talking about problems
is becoming a lot more accepted but when
you were young I imagine your background
that wasn't something mended you know if
you go back all them years I think one
of the main things it would look like
sort of damage and and re-traumatizing
yourself and stuff because you didn't
have the words at the time because of
what I was surrounded by like so I'm
toxic masculinity I was surrounded by
people who were selling drugs people in
gangs people with dogs can't talk about
stuff like that what we do is we build
up and we put these masks on and we walk
about with our HUD shop back then there
was you know there was all this horrible
language around people being gay and and
the words that that people used to use
back then that are disgusting and again
you know like like with with me
pretty much the same we've done like
early on before I found my feet and
become a family person
um I did get caught up in some pretty
mad stuff
and
you know now obviously they call it
coyote lines but the only people that
showed us respect about them were the
people that were either selling drugs to
us
or giving drug source does that make
sense you can't mention that in them
circles so you you'd been through this
process done where you this is a little
bit before you Mike obviously but you
found the ability to speak about it and
how did that manifest after you after
after that moment where you'd found that
voice what happened is
um I went and sought support so the guy
said to me it happened to be a
psychotherapist and he said to me I'll
do your deal I'll get you in detox I'll
get him rehab and when you come out I'll
give you 20 sessions for free at nine
o'clock on a Saturday morning all right
um I've got to see you kind of sort of
commitment and that and um and and I did
it come out I did it I met up with him
and it was one of the most difficult
things I've ever done in my life because
I was like
I'm still even though I was a grown man
um I was in my 30s I still I mean my
emotional development my emotional
intelligence intelligence was probably
about a 13 14 year old boy you know
still making crazy decisions like a kid
would make
um didn't have the words to talk about
what had happened for me for me to heal
it isn't everybody but the devil was in
the detail because I carried this stuff
along around with me my head was like a
washing machine on spin cycle that
washing machine needed opening and um I
had to for me I had to go into specific
detail about what had happened it was
really embarrassing I was full of shame
I was full of guilt because it was like
if you think of 27 it took me 27 years
to disclose so if you think of around
about that time you think about 27 years
of not talking to anybody and keeping
all this stuff to yourself you come up
with your own conclusions about what's
happened start blaming yourself
um you know particularly with the guy
um when I was older when I was 15
because people might think
um you know why don't you just do him in
um why couldn't you get away from him
the thing is it was scary for me to
leave I'll go out into that big wide
world
than it was to stay with him and knew
what was happening and knew I was
getting sexually abused I knew when it
was happening if I went out there to no
one on the streets or whatever nowhere
to live
um I didn't know what was going to
flipping happen
um so I stayed with him until thankfully
for me I got a resident sent to prison
and that's how I kind of um got away
from him really but his back to that
thing nobody ever exercised professional
curiosity even as an adult until it was
like in late adulthood and said Daniel
why are you behaving like this Daniel
what is up with you and that's why one
of our like sort of key messages to
professionals out there is when you see
a child behaving a certain way or act in
a certain way
um you know have that confidence and
courage yeah to ask is everything it's
dead simple it's not rocket science what
we do it's a as something happened to
your arm did something happen to you
when you was a child have you
experienced some kind of trauma there's
a big misconception that
um from professionals drug workers
probation police all them social workers
that if they ask somebody have you
experienced trauma as a child that
they're going to smash into a million
pieces so I've worked with over like 300
men now who've experienced trauma and
from me asking that question to them
nobody's smashed into a million pieces
and people think oh it's going to open a
can of worms
bollocks what it does is it opens up the
door and it gives you an opportunity to
speak do you think that um with your
background you're obviously a very
down-to-earth person do you think it
helps men like Mike open up rather than
somebody that might be a sort of like
educated professional who might not have
experienced things themselves or do you
think it's just as powerful for anyone
to ask the question no educating
professionals right
okay so let's go through that so I went
off doing what I was doing he was doing
what he was doing
um we met up in Manchester City Center
for a kebab and we went over to downdale
car park and we spoke to security and we
went can we go on the roof please and
flip in take some pictures of the city
um and this lo and behold the security
guards let us in and he's walked as
chatting away he's walked us up to the
top floor and we stood
um we stood on the top floor we looked
out over the city center and I said to
Mike me and you between us of course
pure Carnage in this city through
our Behavior as young people selling
drugs coming and crying robbing people
all that kind of stuff well speak from
yourself that was like sort of going on
it's like how can we pay this back we've
caused murders and Mike went let's do a
campaign call follow me arcade and
obviously yeah yeah yeah it's like let's
do a campaign call follow me I couldn't
like what do you mean and we've got like
a pretty decent Twitter platform with
older professionals following us and
stuff
and um we started a campaign and what we
wanted to do is we wanted to focus on
professional curiosity because it's like
what you're doing ain't helping
nothing's changing no one's paying
attention I'm screaming shouting like a
tool at Speaker's Corner and flipping
outside Parliament no one's listening to
me let's put our Reds together and do a
campaign let's speak openly online about
our experiences see what happens so all
the stuff that we've learned about
trauma let's and failures let's pass
that on to professionals and for people
who have been sexually abused will share
our own experiences and hope someone can
connect so you know like he was saying
so as like sort of a man speaking out
about this stuff that really doesn't go
on to be honest with you it's very rare
that you can find someone who's like
started doing that and said let's be
those people
so we started doing this campaign of
within I don't know it must have been
within a month how long ago is this 12
months 12 or 12 months yeah so you you
stopped pedophile hunting then you do
this project we couldn't do the both so
I had not mentioned any known names I'd
spoke about me and my partner up and
people say oh like professionals police
is is a pedophile
uh it's not gonna work blah blah blah so
it was like we need to show this
transition so we've done a video online
say Mike had left hunting and stuff
people still weren't happy about it but
we was like we know what we're doing
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
smash it so we said let's start it up
let's start something called Lads like
us for Lads like us
um and speak about our trauma and share
stuff with professionals up and down the
country now we've got we've got we've
got constantly got heads of services
heads of Social Services
um head to the youth Justice team
all the organization can housing groups
well
um our inbox is bombarded with to come
in and deliver training around
professional curiosity what we're doing
is we're using what we've got which is
our experience which is our lived
experience and the impacts I'm not just
saying it the impacts that we're making
is that is massive and we're just
inundated from heads of organizations up
and down the country to share ours going
from Peter 500 or to being in
partnership with bernardo's so yeah is
that yeah you in public yeah right so
bernardo's contacted us they wanted us
to do a video with them so we did a
video with him a couple of months ago
and and now we deliver training with
bernardos and we're just flooded it's
amazing
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
often people think about therapy and
seeking it out at the point in their
life that they've reached an impassable
obstacle in my personal experience
therapy and counseling is something that
can be used for anything any point in
your life and you can use it for small
problems as well as big problems talking
to people really helps and talking to
licensed counselors can give you a set
of tools that can help you navigate the
stresses and complications of daily life
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists available 100 online
plus it's affordable just fill out a
brief questionnaire to match with a
therapist if things aren't clicking you
can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 of your first month at
betterhelp.com minutes with that's
betterhelp
help.com minutes with and do you feel
like you like what's really Apparent
from both of you guys is like through
whatever paths you've taken it's like it
really feels like you want to help like
you're trying to find ways to help pay
it forward power one paying it forward
but it's like
it is very sort of moving to hear you
talk about the fact that bad things have
happened to you and your main goal is to
make it's not to get revenge or to beat
do you want to talk about demons
I live outside of Manchester now
he lives in central Manchester so I
jumped in the car the other day got my
Starbucks I'm driving down
stuck in traffic on the motorway so I
rang him and I was like oh yeah he's
like yeah I said I'm 20 minutes away
from you
and we was talking about obviously I
coming to London doing the next Lab
Bible and all these different things
and I said to him I was like you know
what I said in in reflection the one
thing I've grown to understand and I've
grown to realize is that all these
demons that I've been running away from
that we've been running away from that
have been constantly causing Carnage in
our lives are actually our best asset
because we've overcome them like who
would we be if we'd not overcome all
that [ __ ] that we've been through
and now you're not it's a pretty
powerful statement now when you think of
it
it's like how can we turn like a
negative into a part into a positive
um they say you can't they say you can't
polish a third
word gleaming you know what I mean we're
like kind of claiming examples of that
and all that this took is by somebody
helping us and and and us
witnessing from other people
suck all that toxic masculinity [ __ ]
aside by vulnerable males in society
speaking out about mental health about
how they're feeling and and and like us
latching on to that and thinking right
God if they can do it we can do it do
not mean there's nothing special about
me and him we've just found our voice
and somebody gave us permission to speak
and that's what we hope will come from
this that people will seek support and
me and him have not smacked he is not
under the table now in the fetal
position don't mean crying because he
spoke about what's happened I'm not what
you're seeing before you know is two men
who are empowered passing stuff onto men
you know what I mean and it's like you
said Mike you know the change isn't
coming the changes already yeah sorry
yeah because we sat here talking about
it now and what do you say there because
what you just said about the demons that
is actually a really powerful statement
because essentially what you're saying
is
where you are now which is your best
versions of yourselves has happened
because of the things that initially set
your lives on a very dark path and I
guess what that means to accept that is
that you you must have grown to love
yourselves yeah without you you can't
love anything else or you love yourself
that's part of the recovery that's part
and not even part of recovery that's
part of the healing process and even if
it's been through any kind of trauma
when it was because it's not their fault
they were children doesn't matter what
kind of drama it is
you know let's let's not just generalize
on sexual abuses there's kids out there
who
I've you know lost a parent or they've
lost a sibling and that trauma is just
as traumatic
sometimes worse
to them because each person reacts to
trauma in a different way
it's about using an elephant in the room
and using the thing that that is
controlled you for so long
getting it in an adlock whacking it in a
Cupboard
and sitting down and having a brew with
it and saying right are we gonna We need
to we need to start this shout out
because there's no way I'm being
controlled by you and that's exactly
what we've done you know we've took all
our Badness
and now we see we know you know in the
past 12 months we've trained over 1300
professionals from from social workers
to police to gas electric universities
up and down the country like the past 12
months has been mental
um where you started is the thing that
happened to you you were very focused on
that thing you know the pedophile
hunting was essentially what happened to
you you were trying to stop that thing
happening again when you're talking
about trauma there it feels like you've
broadened your horizons a lot you're
aware too because you know talking about
pedophilia and rape and sexual abuse to
children so a lot of people it's not
palatable they don't want to talk about
that because that literally is the
elephant in the room that is the taboo
people don't want to hear that you know
it's all good people see it a lot of
Bible video on the internet with a
pedophile or the thing that draws them
to that is the fact that I was a
pedophile Hunter but let's not get it
twisted it's it's a form of trauma
trauma creates behaviors behaviors can
manifest in various different ways and
you know trauma's accountable for a lot
of things in life whatever the trauma is
so it's important that I broaden those
Horizons and learn about the different
types of trauma that I've been through
because it's not just a singular type of
trauma and when you put drama
not in one trough but when you look at
them as all different types of trauma
what you realize is those were adverse
childhood experiences called Aces
and it affects everyone
I think an important point to make here
Mike is that I didn't kind of cover it
before so when we were shouting and
screaming about
um about what had happened to us and the
failures and stuff it was totally
unpalatable for people totally and
palatable for professionals totally
unpalatable for those who was trying to
hold to account and stuff
um so we thought that was another thing
we discussed how can we make this
subject palatable and one of the
um in things at the moment are one of
the buzzwords like Mike said was Aces
adverse childhood experiences and it's
like that's a lot more palatable than
talking about being raped and sexually
abused so we kind of grabbed that hand
stat and presented to the world about
adverse child experiences spoke about
Ira for traumas about parents
disappearing and and all the other kind
of stuff that had happened to us and
that became palatable do you think that
it's helped you a lot that you're
essentially changing the system from
inside the system now yeah because
before you were both outside it weren't
you yeah people arrested and
I'm quite open about the fact that I was
a pedophile Hunter
and you know that's part of my journey
and that's part of the trauma
reenactment and that's part of like I
said here it's about showing that
transition even though Peter Fallen it
was a positive thing it was something
that taught me to a dark place whereas
now I'm not in a dark place and I can
concentrate on the good that I'm doing
whereas then I couldn't because I was
just surrounded by
chat logs of people wanting to work kids
what would you say individually each of
you uh if you want to go first and what
would what's your goal like what when
you get to 70 what do you look back on
and think
I'm glad I achieved that I want to be
part of the generation that says enough
is enough that encouraging other people
to stand up and pay attention to the
damage that trauma causes and encourage
people to
um safeguarding I think everybody's
responsibility it's not just teachers
responsibility it's not just like
police's responsibility as Society we
have a responsibility to safeguard I'll
just sell you something rapid so
um this is what give me a kick up yeah
so guys coming our house to clean our
carpet and he was telling me some
horrific stories about what he's seen by
it while while he's been cleaning
carpets like um you know people beating
up the misses kids neglected [ __ ] up
is everywhere drugs paraphernalia kids
about and I'm like what did you what
what did you do about it oh nothing
because my name's on company alsoever
say anything about it someone might come
around to my house but it's like
safeguarding wasn't his responsibility
do you know what I mean but how do we
expect things to change if if everyone's
got the head in the flipping Sun like a
flipping ostrich you know what I mean
what we want to do is oh what I believe
we're doing is as pirate pioneering
um a trauma informed um wave up and down
the country and we are actually doing
that to the point we've just got
flipping National where we're delivering
stuff up and down the country and we
want to leave a legacy behind for our
kids that's what I want to do beautiful
answer how about you Mike pretty much
what you said honestly you know it's
liberating he's liberating I don't
really you know I already thought I kind
of left a little bit of a legacy for me
kids with everything that I did but the
fact that through the internet and
obviously through you guys they've been
able to see
the transition when they're older
they'll be able to look back and say
well you know that's where he started
and that's where I ended up
I've not just left it and kind of got a
nine to five like evolved we've evolved
and got
I don't know how many hours at work now
if you could speak to your target
audience to people you're trying to
reach uh what would you want to say to
them be professionally curious you know
instead of looking at the case look at
the child
you know remember especially to the
professionals that'll see this you know
people like social workers people that
do work within the police people that do
work with vulnerable people whether that
be children or vulnerable adults these
people are vulnerable for a reason
and sometimes yeah they might behave in
certain ways but it's about looking
beyond the behavior
and more towards the cause of the
behavior Max could have covered the
professional side I think my message
would be for people who have been
sexually abused and
um I think it's really important that um
you know there's this thing this is term
this terminology that's banded about
that's called being a Survivor as in
someone who's experienced sexual abuse
abuse and and it's like it kind of sort
of ends there and you just stuck as a
Survivor so for me I was a victim for
many years and also kind of started
rightly so in some ways like so I played
the victim look at me look what's
happened to me in my life is [ __ ] I'm
going to be angry at the world I'm gonna
commit crime I'm going to ruin everybody
else's life and I was stuck in victim
mode and
um the reason for that is I've got
comfortable with me on [ __ ] because the
the thought of speaking out and the
thought of moving forward the talk of
the thought of talking about what's
happened to me seemed too scary
um so when that guy spoke to me and
encouraged me to speak out and give me
permission to speak I stopped surviving
what I did is then as I started live in
I dropped that victimhood that victim
mentality I stop surviving because
surviving just means I was just like
getting through the day I was taking a
lot of drugs to survive I was committing
crime I was hanging about with all kinds
of different people well I thought I'd
fitted in I wasn't living when I dropped
that Survivor stuff
um you know and realized I'm gonna make
it I survived it you know I mean what's
next
um what's next is I started Living
started enjoying my life stopped looking
over me shoulder stopped always focusing
on the past and and just like so I'm
moving forward I'm not saying I don't
have [ __ ] days I'm not saying you're
gonna have [ __ ] days because I do but if
I consort myself out he can sort himself
out there ain't nothing special about me
and him and you can sort yourself out
just go and seek support what I'm saying
is do your research first find out what
support services around your area find
someone you trust to speak to who can
support you who's going to listen to you
and see you through the process and and
you can do it that's a wonderful message
and listen you're both a really
inspirational pair of guys it's been a
pleasure to know you and to meet you
thanks um and we will stay in touch and
hopefully in a couple of years there'll
be another update yeah even more news in
the world domination you mentioned
thanks very much
when I was 24.
and the opening lines uh Jonathan was
born on the say first of the 10th 1984.
and both parents were horrified by the
child's appearance both parents felt no
maternal Bond both parents left the
hospital 36 hours later leaving the
child behind